LGBTQ but we have diversity
geographically generationally and across
the country
in every possible way we have diversity
and diversity of opinion people thanked
me for being a unifier of our caucus but
that isn't true what unifies our caucus
are our values and the overriding value
that supersedes any differences we may
have is our commitment to America's
working families that is why I am so
proud to stand here that's why I'm so
proud to stand here with Richard Trumka
the president's Maaf at afl-cio Chris
Shelton president of Communication
Workers of America Jennifer Durning
president for professional and
Department of professional employees of
the afl-cio John Samuelson president
Transport Workers Union Jim Slevin
president utility workers union of
America Tim Driscoll president
international union of bricklayers and
allied craft workers and representatives
of many other unions who are here with
us today I'm proud to join the chair of
the education and Labor Committee
chairman Bobby Scott and salute him for
his leadership he's a champion of
workers
some members of his committee are with
us congresswoman Frederica Wilson who's
what chair of the subcommittee that
produced the proact Donald Sussman of
New Jersey from Allah jeyapaul of Donald
Norcross of New Jersey a real champion a
former member of a union himself and
again a champion for America's working
families probably proud to be going to
New Jersey to be with him shortly
Pramila jeyapaul of washington state and
representative Andy levin one of our
freshman members but effective from the
start for America's workers again this
is about stemming the assault that the
Republicans are making on the rights of
working men and women in our country
many of you know that we all believe
that the middle class is the backbone of
our democracy and you all know also that
the middle class has a union label on it
so I thank our friends in labor for
their patriotism and I'm proud to be
able to be here with them with this
legislation and what it does it holds
companies that violate workers rights
accountable strengthens workers sacred
collective bargaining rights and
protects access to fair union elections
but you'll hear more about that from our
members of Congress I also want to
acknowledge that we have a VIP here
she's our special guest of honor
Jennifer WOMAC
and she is a person who will tell us of
her experience and that is what is
important about legislation how it
affects America's workers and with that
I'm very pleased to yield to the
distinguished chair of the education and
Labor Committee chairman Bobby Scott me
thank you
thank you madam Speaker and thank you
for your tremendous leadership of the
house thank you everyone for being with
us today and the protecting the right to
organize act confronts a serious and
urgent challenge and that is that
American economy is not working for most
American workers while corporate profits
are at record have many workers and
their families are struggling to keep
pace with rising costs of housing health
care education and other basic
essentials throughout their history
America's labor unions have ensured that
workers receive a fair share of the
profits they produce when workers have
the power to stand together to form a
union they have higher pay better
benefits surfers and surfers and safer
work conditions even the children of
union members lead better lives and pay
gaps disappear in union contracts for
those working in similar jobs men and
women blacks and whites all get equal
pay for equal work even non-union
members benefit because when union wages
go up to compete other wages have to go
up but after decades of anti labor
attacks membership is at its lower level
since just after the National Labor
Relations Act was enacted in 1935 and it
is not a coincidence that has union
membership decreases income inequality
increases the proact is a comprehensive
proposal that makes necessary reforms to
US labor law this legislation will help
strengthen workers power to stand
together to negotiate with their
employers hold companies accountable for
violating employer employees rights
helps guarantee workers can decide for
themselves whether to form a union
without interference and ensures that
all workers have the protection sections
and rights they need to survive in
today's economy the proact
is the most significant upgrade u.s.
labor laws in 80 years and as a major
step towards creating an economy where
everyone can succeed I'm grateful for
the workers and advocates across the
country
who've helped advance the legislation
and it is now my pleasure to introduce
the president of the afl-cio Richard
Trumka
good afternoon and thank you
Speaker Pelosi for your leadership
friendship and guidance chairman Scott
for all that you do the members of the
house that are here with us all my
brothers and sisters that are showed up
today and especially one special person
and that's Jennifer WOMAC and Jennifer I
wanna thank you for your courage in all
of this how many of you saw the
commercial
the Verizon's commercial on Super Bowl
Sunday it captured the duty the
responsibility and the humanity of
America's first responders who risked
their lives for our safety and while it
was a nice reminder about the importance
of our connection to each other it
really didn't tell the whole story
when Jennifer and her co-workers tried
to form one of the most personal and
powerful bonds possible and that's a
union as members of the Communication
Workers of America verizon said no you
see 5g might be able to do a lot of
exciting things but it cannot fix our
broken and outdated labor laws at
Verizon and elsewhere
in more than 40% of all union organizing
drives employers simply break the law
they lie they coerce in some cases they
fire union supporters workers are forced
to attend mandatory meetings with one
item on the agenda and that's to make
people afraid to exercise our right to
form a union and these messages of fear
and intimidation are coming from the
very people who control our paychecks
who control how much time we can spend
with our family and control whether
we'll have a job in six months or a year
down the road
now that's how you end up with an
economy where more than 60 million
people say they would vote to join a
union today but only one in 10 actually
have one workers went in and is it any
wonder why simply put workers in unions
bargain for higher wages are much more
likely to have health care and pensions
the Union advantage is even greater for
people of color unionized workers have a
real say in a critical workplace issues
like time off to care for a loved one -
the development of technology and
protection from discrimination now the
National Labor Relations Act passed in
1935 was a beacon of the New Deal I
assured in a new era where workers
organizing to win could win for equality
to get our share of the American Dream
and that wave of worker voice changed
the direction of America when workers
started getting unions America changed
and we built the greatest middle class
that the world has ever seen
but
but the NLRA has been weakened
continuously in the 85 years since its
inception and an entire union-busting
industry spending billions of dollars
each year now works non-stop to block
workers from exercising the freedom that
the law is supposed to protect now is
the time in fact it's way past time to
protect the right to organize for
workers in the 21st century the proact
is how we do it and it's not an
exaggeration to say that this is the
most significant piece of legislation
that will come before the House of
Representatives this year it protects
the right to strike it Trump's the right
to work sham it ensures a process for
reaching a first contract once the
unions recognized it provides
substantial relief for workers whose
rights have been violated and creates a
true deterrent so employers think twice
about violating the law it also removes
the employers standing in representation
cases because the choice to form a union
must belong to Jennifer and her
co-workers and not Verizon and its
executives
so we call upon the house to pass the
proact we call on all members of
Congress Republican and Democrat to
support the proact
we call on the Senate to follow the
house of suit and pass the proact and
then we call on President Trump to sign
that bill in the law and those who would
oppose delay or derail this legislation
do not ask us do not ask the labor
movement for a dollar or a door knock we
won't be coming
stand with us today and we'll stand with
you tomorrow because Jennifer and her
co-workers deserved nothing less in fact
Americans workers deserve nothing less
thank you
and now I have the distinct pleasure and
honor and that's not just a prelude to
an end of introduction I really mean it
Jennifer WOMAC is a Verizon she worked
for Verizon Wireless in Irving Texas and
she knows how inadequate our current
labor laws are she has the courage to
stand up and not help not only herself
but every other worker that comes in
touch with her Jennifer it's an honor to
have you here
good afternoon my name is Jennifer WOMAC
I've worked the Verizon Wireless Center
call center in Irving Texas for the last
three years I'm glad that my job allows
me to provide important services for our
customers but I've also noticed a number
of problems in our work environment in
fact when I first started many of my
co-workers told me that they were having
trouble getting paid while out on
medical leave I could not figure out why
this would be a problem but then I had
to miss work while having surgery to
remove my gallbladder my doctor sent in
all the paperwork yet I was stuck
without pay while I was our covering and
my bills were mounting up I remember
being in pain
crying why was land up recovering being
on the phone with our benefits company
time and time again trying to figure out
why my pay was not being approved
I was not ultimately paid for my medical
leave until I returned to work and there
are other problems too for example one
manager at our call center who was a
white man wear an afro wig at work a
number of times this was offensive to me
and a lot of my co-workers most of whom
were african-american the manager
ultimately had to apologize but he was
never disciplined for this in fact he
recently received a company award
instead so you can imagine why some of
my co-workers and I wanted to form a
union but right after we discard we
started discussing joining together in a
union the company began to force us to
attend mandatory union trainings in
which they kept telling us why forming a
union would hurt us sometimes the jump
team calls workers they suspect may
support organizing into those trainings
at a moment's notice those trainings
terrified a lot of people eventually I
asked our CEO about this a Verizon share
holding meeting but after that happened
my wife my life got even worse the
company isolated me
from my co-workers and some people I was
close to we're afraid to even talk to me
it's also become harder for me
personally to use my time off I'm often
required to use my emergency days before
my personal days even though this is not
company policy and managers have tried
to humiliate me publicly in front of my
co-workers trying to make it seem like
I've done something wrong this
retaliation makes it very difficult for
workers to form a union if we want to
I believe that decision of whether to
join together in a union should be up to
me and other workers without having us
to face threats and retaliation that's
why
that's why I'm so glad that the house
has taken up the proact this bill will
put together put power back in the hands
of workers like me to make our own
decisions about forming a union without
risking our jobs I'm especially glad
that the bill would ban the sort of
mandatory anti-union trainings that we
faced it's also really important that
the bill imposes real penalties on
companies that break the law since the
right since right now it seems like
companies can get away with pretty much
anything with just a slap on the wrist I
believe that everyone should be treated
fairly and be able to have a voice on
the job the proact
is a great sell step to help achieve
that thank you
and that's next I wanna introduce
representative Wilson
she's a star a champion let's give out
another round of applause
madam Speaker a wonderful champion thank
you so much
mr. chairman thank you and to all of our
friends of Labor I'm honored to stand
with you today as we strengthen
bargaining rights for American workers
as the chair of the health subcommittee
led to long hearings and work
consistently to support the probe this
legislation is about restoring workers
right to organize and improving living
and working conditions in every single
community as a proud member of the
United Teachers of Dade in Miami I
experienced firsthand the benefits of
collective bargaining and union
membership because of the United
Teachers of days hard-fought
negotiations and contract I had good
dental health health insurance adequate
sick leave for me and I helped health
care for my children as a widowed mother
of three these benefits made the world
of difference I can only imagine the
difficulties my children and I would
have faced at my employer worked to
suppress my right to join a union
anyone who has gotten a livable wage
equal pay and equal work in a safe
working environment should thank unions
and support the proact
anyone anyone walk in a middle-class
home and is fighting to build a
middle-class home or they're all
children should thank unions and support
the proyect
strong you play a central role in
building a robust middle class in this
country and they are essential to
rebuilding it again this important
legislation helped turns the ties on
decades of wage stagnation income
inequality and pervasive employer in
timid ation we must stop that now
workers deserve the right to negotiate
for a fair share of the wealth wealth
that their hard labor and hard work
helped to create simply put if you claim
to fight for and support the interests
of working people you must support the
pro if you claim to be the American
dream
you must support the proact thank you
and I obey
it is my pleasure to bring to the podium
my fellow committee member
Representative Norcross good afternoon
this is a unbelievable day take you back
to 1977 I was a single dad trying to
find my way in the world and I had to
make a decision I had three brothers of
went to college I enjoyed working with
my hands so I went to the other
four-year school was called him
premiership from that point up to today
I've been a member of the IBEW a proud
member so why is that important I went
on to be a business agent in the Union
and it's true not many people go from
the construction site to Congress but I
was one of those and why is that
important I could look around the room
with people that I've worked with over
the years who understand what it's like
to get laid off be out on disability not
have the dignity of working for a
paycheck but when they're employed and
they're not being treated well people
understand who's got the power the
company that can pay lawyers to go fight
their fight delay delay delay or you who
lives paycheck to paycheck and you know
if you get fired you're putting your
family at risk
see that's what I saw over my 30 years
I've been TNR be upheld elections we
tried to organize and it's about delay
delay fire intimidate it's not a level
playing field and that's what we're
talking about today it's leveling the
playing field to make sure those workers
if they want to can join together
you heard rich Trumka talk about 60
million people with joining unity if it
was fair but it's not it's not fair and
today we start to change that this has
been so long in coming for those of you
who've been to the NRB and you see those
lawyers with the big suits coming in you
know spending a thousand bucks an hour
for a company it's nothing that's two
weeks paycheck
bring it up every week and we have and
here we are at this great day I am also
proud to be from a state Washington
state that has the third highest union
density in the country and let us be
clear that that is linked to the fact
that we were the first state in the
country to link minimum wage to
inflation we have some of the best per
worker policies and it is thanks to
workers and labor unions for pushing
those policies forward so you've heard
some of what happens I wanted to give
you a few statistics just imagine that
employers spend roughly three hundred
and forty million dollars annually on
union avoidance consultants just imagine
that more than half of workers who vote
to form a union do not have a collective
bargaining agreement even one year later
imagine that employees can be
permanently replaced for striking for a
fair contract and as Jennifer said that
employers face very very few penalties
when you go to work the proact says that
you should not lose your ability to
speak up you should always be able to
advocate for yourself for your medical
needs for your family and your
colleagues when you see your experienced
injustice but we're in a situation where
years of anti worker anti-union policies
have eroded those basic rights and a
symptom of that stark power imbalance
between workers and employers is the
unacceptable income inequality that we
face across this country just two days
into 2020 the average CEO of a fortune
500 company earned more than the average
employee will earn all year labor unions
are that powerful tool to address this
imbalance to put power back into the
hands of workers
and ultimately to write an economy that
has gone way off track in terms of
delivering justice for everyone and
unionized black and Latino workers will
earn more than they do now when they're
non-unionized unionized female workers
understand are paid ninety four percent
of a unionized males pay far smaller
than the overall gender wage gap so it's
time to rebalance our economy and it is
going to be a truly great day in the
United States House of Representatives
when we pass the protecting the right to
organize act and we put power back into
the hands of workers thank you so much
[Applause]
and now let me turn it over to a great
champion of labour one of our great new
members of Congress representative and
11 from the state of Michigan Thank You
Pamela madam Speaker
chairman Scot chairwoman Wilson it's
just an incredible honor to be standing
here on this historic day president
trumka Jennifer taking on you didn't
think you'd have to maybe when you
started I didn't know all your story
going to the shareholder meeting that
takes guts she's taking on one of the
biggest corporations in this country and
all we're saying is you shouldn't have
to do that why should your boss be
involved in your decision about whether
or not to form a union 85 years it's
been 85 years since the Wagner Act was
passed and this Congress hasn't passed a
paragraph of legislation that makes it
easier for workers to form unions and
bargain collectively and we've passed
some major legislation over President
Truman's veto during President
Eisenhower's time that makes it harder
for workers to form unions right after
World War two a third of private-sector
workers had unions when I started
organizing nursing home workers with
SEIU in nineteen eighty three sixteen
and a half percent of private-sector
workers have unions and last week the
BLS announced just 6.2 percent of
workers have the voice and power to come
together and bargain a contract to get a
better life for themselves and their
kids all we're asking for is freedom a
free market for union representation let
workers decide by themselves and for a
union organizer nerd like me this bill
is so full of many different pieces that
take care of the anti-union problems
that have been created through judicial
decisions administrative actions and
ledges
relation over the last 85 years when we
passed this law it's gonna be a
beautiful new day and the American dream
is going to be able to come back into
sight of our working-class people in
this country madam Speaker thank you so
much it's such an honor to be here the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
and close it off Nancy Pelosi so here we
are a day away from passing this
historic important legislation we all
want to talk about a seat at the table
the most important table to us is
America's kitchen tables where families
come together to make their decisions
about their families and we don't want
them to have to struggle unnecessarily
when there is a an opportunity for them
to do better and I want to thank the
afl-cio or all in the labor movement for
what they have done to make the future
better for so many families in America I
particularly want to say that equal pay
for equal work as a principle that we
would love to have established in the
Congress we passed it in the house we
wanted to be passed in the Senate for
the whole country the labor movement has
been in the lead from Rosie to River
even going all the way back even
probably before then so thank you for
that and last night we heard that low
income people's wages were going up and
wasn't that wonderful what had nothing
to do with a person who was talking
about it had to do with raising the
minimum wage as a giant Paul mentioned
throughout the country and that was with
them under the leadership of the afl-cio
the fight for 15 which we passed in the
house we hope to pass in the Senate but
it has been enacted into law in many
many states in our country in our city
of San Francisco as well and that is
because of the leadership of the afl-cio
last night I talked to young woman well
she was young to me so and she told me
and we when we came into Congress the
first time in the majority in 2007 the
first 100 hours we passed an increase in
the minimum
that was 2007 there hasn't been an
increase since then so that meant not
working what 725 an hour for all these
years without the right to organize to
do better there hasn't been a race for
her since 2000 in 12 years and having to
be a mom and raise a family and the rest
of that so with the leadership of the
afl-cio were doing so many things
including lifting up everyone it was
increasing the minimum wage but as
chairman chairman Scott mentioned even
if you don't belong who union the lift
that the labor movement gives to all
workers lifts everyone up so I thank you
for that this is so important to America
it's so important to our economy our
economy nothing is more important to our
economy the education of our children
and and also to have purchasing power on
the part of the middle class that can
only happen when workers get respected
for the work that they do and receive
the wages and the salaries that they
deserve and so this Pro Act is a vehicle
in that direction it's going to be a day
of celebration we're very excited about
it and we hope to have a big strong vote
and we invite Republicans to join us for
that for for for the American people for
the children thank you all very much
[Applause]
I'm gonna get into the hotel I'm in the
Beijing Grand Hyatt there is pretty much
nobody here so this ice-skating rink
just opened before the Lunar New Year
holiday and now it's closed again
normally there are kids shoulder to
shoulder on this but it is empty now I'm
outside one of the gates of the
Forbidden City it's still closed a lot
of the major public landmarks in China
are still closed all of these shared
bikes here but nobody's